[Music]
all right let's go to austin
texas
what's up jeremy
what's up john how you doing man i'm hey
we're partying and you guys are yeah
it's a thousand degrees there man what
are you doing
we kind of we kind of skipped a
old spring and just jumped right into
late august it's kind of uh
yeah it's you know we're staying inside
i was there a few weeks ago it was
something else man like i grew up in
texas and i was like this is not texas
hot this is
hell hot this is hot hot yeah yeah
it's it's kind of ridiculous it's you
know everyone
yeah everyone that's older than me like
keeps saying oh it just reminds me 1980
i'm like
i wasn't alive then but i'm pretty hot
enough to remember that specific date
cool thanks man that oh cool cool that's
great all right so what's up man what's
up exactly yeah so
uh i'm
trying to figure out how to plan my
eight-month-old first
birthday or first year birthday party
uh which sounds uh relatively simple but
my my wife and i keep getting stuck on
the question of what to do with our
parents so his our son's grandparents
which both of our
my parents are divorced my wife's
parents are divorced and
uh didn't you think about having
divorced grandparents oh you got a bunch
of grandparents don't you
yeah six
six and you know potentially in the
future maybe eight so uh who knows but
why not man why not
yeah so like we dealt with that as kids
and that that story is you know
unfortunately pretty common but i hadn't
ever thought in my life the same way we
hadn't thought about
what that looks like for grandkids or
even how to deal with those situations
and we really really want to avoid
those kind of
pains and
the
you know everything that goes along with
the divorce for for children we do not
want our son to even get a hint of that
so part of it is like what do we do with
these
these events so like starting very
practically with
his his
some of these
grandparents like these sort of events
and they like you know they're really
big on it
so initially we're like let's just
invite them all and
tell them to suck it up
and then i would think wouldn't that be
awful if they all showed up
okay so
here let me let me give you a couple of
quick things you can do to frame this
whole thing
okay okay yeah please
number one
a birthday is the way you tell somebody
you love them
yeah
it is not a
a an event to show the world how rich
you are how cool and creative you are
or
it's not an event for honoring
grandparents they get their birthday
and so yeah absolutely start the
planning of this thing by taking them
completely out of the picture
okay
how can we best honor this little
one-year-old kid
and that might be a couple of friends
that might be going to the zoo that
might be this is gonna sound crazy
that might be getting a
hose and letting it run in the backyard
for 20 minutes and making a big mud hole
and y'all just sitting in it with them
and then getting some cupcakes perfect
you know what i mean like your
one-year-old will think that's the
greatest party ever and then when
they're looking at pictures and they're
10 and they're like what is that that's
when we had a mudhole birthday and and
the 10 year old will go that's amazing
and then the 18 year old would be like
do we really have a mudhole birthday and
you'll be like yes number one we have
111 grandparents and we didn't want to
deal with it number two you love mud
holes
you see what i'm saying
yeah so i guess i guess the rest of my
question would be like
i guess all of it the rest of his
boundaries they're going to be like hey
we want to we want to have a party at
our house and we want to have a party at
our house and then so here's a beautiful
thing we're not going anywhere okay i
want you to repeat after me it's going
to be amazing okay all right take a big
deep breath and hold it
hold it one mississippi two mississippi
threes okay let it out
are you ready
yeah repeat after me
no thank you
no thank you or even better
we're not going to be able to make that
this year but we will consider it next
year
yeah that's that's a that's a good one
okay so that one a lot actually yes you
should
so
um
your both of your your parents have made
choices in their life for various
reasons
right and those choices have
consequences that extend beyond time my
dad used to tell me to picture all of my
choices like throwing a rock in the
middle of a lake and those ripples just
keep rippling out and they end up on
different parts of the shore of that
pond
minutes and sometimes hours later right
so
they made choices and they continue to
make choices
your child your eight-month-old
is not in service to the choices they
have made
absolutely yeah okay and neither is your
young marriage and neither is your
parenting
and so here's in all honesty here's how
i would handle this
okay i would get with my wife and say
what do we want to do this year that
will best honor our one-year-old
i think having family involved honors a
one-year-old right it's generational
it's all those things
um
what is the best way we can do that are
the adults in our life mature
do they act like morons are they going
to act in because if they are going to
show up in pick fights and so-and-so is
going to be drinking and
uncle so-and-so is going to be smoking
marble reds in the living room whatever
the thing is
um that's not honoring that one-year-old
right right so it may be that you send
an email email out to everyone and say
we are not going to split up and do 50
different birthday parties we're going
to do one
if you can be adults and everybody show
up at the same time
then you're all welcome at our house at
this time and we're gonna have hot dogs
and cake and it's over at three
that's it it's over
if you can't then great
no worries
and i would leave it at that
yeah or the adults about it that's right
or we are choosing to have a friends
only birthday this year for the
one-year-old birthday
um
we'd like to celebrate birthday with you
so at christmas when we come visit or
when you all come visit we're happy to
celebrate the birthday then
and that would be it that would be the
half birthday they're like a reverse
half birthday i guess
yeah yeah yeah um but it's establishing
those boundaries and then do not budge
and this is your is this kid number one
it is kid number one okay so it's kid
number one and birthday number one so
when you put these boundaries up expect
there to be grenades and missiles and
all kind of bulldozers slamming up
against your boundaries to see if they
hold
for sure there will be adult temper
tantrums there will be all the things
this is about honoring that kid and one
other quick piece of advice for you
yeah absolutely
you cannot hide the fact that there's
divorce in your family from your child
right yeah yeah we're not trying to hide
the fact necessarily just be the
i guess it's just the fear of like him
having to go through the things that we
did
and right that's just a matter of my
wife and i not getting divorced really
exactly you all have a work really hard
on your great marriage and by the way
setting boundaries like this together
is one of those tactile ways to solidify
your marriage right yeah for sure it's a
it's a coin in the in the bank right so
that's where that team bond really
developed yes and so play the scenario
out with your wife y'all could make a
fun game with this um
or it could be a teary mess of a game
uh because
all of us have that picture of that
first birthday and all the adults are
around and they all got just the right
gift and everybody's pulling out candles
everybody's acting mature and then
there's reality
and it may be i'm in favor of the the
mud hole man honestly like i think
i grew up i'm not a fan of birthdays my
wife is into birthdays and
uh her side of the family is and
everything so like a lot of that
pressure is just you know birthdays are
important i'm like ah it's just a you
know another spin around the sun but i
think what you're saying about it being
a marker of honoring our son
is a really really good way of thinking
of it
i i i i think
birthdays and funerals
are
moments to pause
and let somebody know i love you
that's why you never miss a funeral
because like a birthday everybody
gathers in a room to say we love this
person
and birthdays are similar
and if people cannot act i don't care
who they are if they can't act with
maturity and they can't act not for
their own sense of self but
on behalf of this little one
and this little one's gonna turn out to
be a 17 year old right and people like
people buy crazy gifts but they buy
gifts because they have turned it into a
competition um i've talked to folks
whose in-laws like compete to buying
presents one in-law is super wealthy
one's not there's a million different
versions of this yeah all those dynamics
exist in this situation of course
we don't want to we don't want to deal
with any of that stuff so we're just
going to opt out and it might be this
it might be that you say we're going to
alternate year after year and so just
like in my family we do thanksgiving one
and we do christmas the other me and my
wife do with our our separate families
and then this is part of that yeah
this year i think we're gonna we're
gonna blow it off all right
this year i think we're gonna blow it
off and we're gonna um we're gonna go do
christmas like just with me and my wife
and our two little kids we're gonna like
go on a trip we've never done that yeah
that's how we do right that's our life
we can do whatever we want to with it
right
yeah exactly exactly and so it may be
that hey this year we celebrate it with
this side of the family and next year
y'all this side of the family gets
invited to the birthday party but
all that to say is let's start with that
one window and then work backwards is
that fair right and i imagine at some
point you know our son is we're going to
give him agency into some of these
decisions about what he wants to do for
his birthday but you know for this first
one it's our first kid and you know
we're just
trying to be as intentional as possible
with
you know
to expose them to as much love as
possible but also balances between the
crazies all right so because these are
these are all always grandparents love
and love and love him of course no doubt
in my mind about that it's just you know
that all these histories that they've
you know what you're talking about with
the ripples in the pond
uh
has come down to the third generation so
we're trying to figure that out and it
may be
man it may be one of those shapeshifter
moments for your family
but a joint email
from you and your wife to everybody
that was just called it out i don't know
if i recommend this i'm just gonna think
out loud real quick
but just call out
we're all adults here
we all me and
wife her wife and husband grew up as
children of divorced parents it was hard
there was lots of back and forth there
was lots of chaos there was lots of
fights there was lots of new marriages
there's lots of new girlfriends and
boyfriends whatever whatever y'all story
is
the key there's chaos
the key there is angst
and we have committed to not
putting our kids through what we
experienced now you saying that out loud
is going to put your parents on the
defensive
you me yes that happened they have to
own that yep
we got divorced for whatever what's
because billy slept with susan i don't
care why it happened it happened
and we're committed to not doing that so
if y'all can show up to a birthday party
and be adults no presents allowed none
no presents we do not want your gifts
here we're fine uh if you want to have a
gift put an endowment in a college fund
i've opened a 528 you're free to put
money into that that's going to be his
gifts forever
if y'all can show up and everybody's
here and everybody's smiling and
everybody's fun and there's no tension
great
if you can't you can't cool we're just
not gonna have you and we'll see you
christmas or we'll see it thanksgiving
and if you're gonna act super immature
or be abusive or decide i ever see
um there's something powerful about that
it will cause problems make no mistake
about it it will cause problems but
there's something that's just like i
don't know man i kind of like it like
this is just where we are this is where
we are but all i have to say is get with
your wife and you'll get really specific
how can we honor this little one how can
we show this this this this little one
your wife's right by the way celebrate
birthdays man they're important we love
you we love you
and then set those boundaries with the
family
and then
hold firm because they're coming